Привіт, мене звати Кеті Бесладо.
Я директор зі стратегії IBM Quantum
та досліджень застосунків. Я тут, щоб розвінчати
якнайбільше міфів про квантові обчислення
за шістдесят секунд.
Одна з прекрасних речей — це те, що вони абсолютно реальні,
і в нас є пристрої в хмарі IBM, до яких може отримати доступ кожен.
Так, але лише для певних задач — тих, у яких вони справді гарні:
надскладна математика на кшталт тієї, за якою працює Всесвіт.
Але якщо тобі потрібні таблиці чи пошта — використовуй
свій ПК.
Так, теоретично, але не
найближчим часом — ніхто ще не створив достатньо потужний комп'ютер для цього.
Поки що, у зримому майбутньому, ми на правильному шляху,
і коли ми до цього прийдемо, то змінимо спосіб захисту
інформації.
Це абсолютна неправда — квантові комп'ютери
принципово відрізняються
і використовують закони природи для обробки інформації.
Сучасний ШІ працює на старих добрих класичних пристроях,
але ми впевнені, що в майбутньому вони співпрацюватимуть.
Це неправда — у нас є величезна екосистема
стартапів, академічних установ, національних лабораторій та промислових партнерів,
які використовують наші пристрої щодня.
Ні, квантово-натхненні підходи існують
вже давно і працюють на класичних пристроях — вони
ніколи не реалізують справжній потенціал квантових обчислень.
Якщо тобі потрібні квантові обчислення, ти маєш використовувати справжні квантові
комп'ютери.